sí sin duda juan creo que el mensaje del
rey carlos tercero ha sido bien claro en
intentar dar el mensaje de la
continuidad ha dicho la reina ha muerto
enviamos nuestros más sentidos y grandes
condolencias y tributo a él a su madre
por supuesto pero ha dejado claro que
hay continuidad y me parece importante
también resaltar ese gesto que podría
considerarse espontáneo pero el rey
carlos es uno de sus primeros actos como
monarca fue de venir a saludar a las
multitudes que estaban en las afueras
del palacio de buckingham desde hace
muchísimas horas ha sido diferente el
acercamiento porque los ha tocado de la
mano se ha dejado dar besos abrazos así
que yo creo que él carlos con este
discurso del primero el más importante
por supuesto porque es el primero que
hace como jefe de estado británico no
solamente de él como wells además sino
rey de otros 18 países también él ha
querido dar ese mensaje de que hay
continuidad la reina isabel ha muerto
era esa figura el símbolo de unidad del
país pero él quiere decir que hay futuro
y también me parece importante que en
este mensaje el primero ha hablado del
príncipe william que es ahora el primero
en la línea de sucesión al trono y de su
esposa kate así que eso enfatiza más la
idea de lo que se viene hablando hace
muchos años de qué tipo de reinado puede
tener carlos tercero y definitivamente
ya ha quedado claro va a ser esa idea de
que la monarquía para poder mantenerse
en el tiempo tiene que ser más pequeña y
teniendo como protagonistas a los reyes
al rey carlos a su esposa a la reina
consorte camila parker bowles al
príncipe de gales
william y a su esposa la duquesa de
cornwall kate middleton así que creo que
esto es bien importante y si me permites
inicia también ha iniciado en la
catedral de samples una de las más
características del reino unido- aquí en
londres es un servicio de remembranza
para y rendir un tributo a la reina
isabel y por primera vez se ha cantado
god save the king